nous voici en direct de l'Université des
maire de l'Ouest parisien avec Pierre
béer bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
président du conseil départemental des
ivelines euh vous êtes à une université
des mares ma c'est une fonction que vous
avez exercé que vous avez aimé je
suppose passionnément passionnément et
justement j'ai une question parce que
c'est on voit qu'il y a peut-être une
sorte de malaise des mè alors je parle
pas c'est vrai qu'il y a eu les émeutes
il y a les il y a les incivilités ça
c'est c'est mais je parle du rapport des
au fond des élus locaux et de l'état on
a l'impression qu'il a une
incompréhension euh peut-être qui vient
de l'État qui peut-être qu' vient du
chef de l'État euh qu'est-ce que quelle
est votre analyse là-dessus je crois
qu'il y a un double phénomène qui euh
rend euh le quotidien des maires très
différent de celui que j'ai connu c'est
que d'une part les dotations d'État
c'est-à-dire que l'aide que l'État est
censé apporter à chaque citoyen dans
chaque commune est en chute libre et ce
depuis très longtemps maintenant que en
faisant cela l'État n'a pas pour autant
donné la liberté fiscale aux communes
elle l'a il l'a au contraire amoindr
donc pasautonomie il y a pas d'autonomie
puisque il n'y a plus on le sait bien la
taxe d'habitation alors c'est très bien
pour les gens qui ne la payent plus mais
c'est dramatique pour les services
rendus dans les communes parce que où
trouver l'argent si l'État ne paye pas
dans les dotations et s'il décide par la
loi de supprimer l'impôt qui était
l'impôt principal ou trouver l'argent et
et donc les maires sont accablés par les
soucis financier c'est faire le budget
chaque année est un casse-tê renouvelé
et c'est pour eux de plus en plus
pénible vous ajoutez à ça que le le lien
avec le citoyen se distant un peu le
citoyen se comporte de plus en plus en
consommateur et de moins en moins en
citoyen connaissez la célèbre phase de
John filzeral Kennedy ne te demande pas
ce qu'on peut faire pour toi demande-toi
ce que tu peux faire il faudrait que les
gens se demandent ce qu'ils peuvent
faire pour leur commune le bénévolat qui
chute bah c'est forcément des gens qu'il
faut recruter pour remplacer les
bénévoles or on a de l'argent en moins
donc c'est cette double crise me
semble-t-il que les maires ont as
supporté et je les plains parce que
l'époque que j'ai connu était bien plus
heureuse on parle depuis quelques années
de la nécessité d'un choc de
décentralisation il vient pas ah il est
loin de venir puisqu'on est en réalité
et devant une recentralisation mais avec
un état qui n'a pas les moyens de cette
recentralisation ni les moyens
financiers ni les moyens humains il a
plus les compétences et souvent c'est
très frappant quand j'entends le
président de la République parler de
décentralisation en réalité il parle de
déconcentration déconcentrationd c'est
pas la même chose la décentralisation
c'est confié aux élus locaux des
responsabilités la déconcentration c'est
confié à des responsables de l'État dans
les collectivités ou dans les les
départements des pouvoirs
supplémentaires or à la limite ça
pourrait être une décision mais l'État
dans les départements et dans les
arrondissements est de plus en plus
faible et donc ils ne peuvent pas faire
le travail qu'on leur demande est-ce que
SII dans une période où il y a de grands
changement par exemple la transition
écologique qui qui est tout à fait
nécessaire mais où on voit qu'il y a
quand même une complexité grandissante
des textes de l'administration de la de
la technocratie euh ça ne complique pas
aussi la le rôle des élus ah vous avez
1000 fois raison c'est la la célèbre
phrase de Paul Valée tout ce qui est
simple est faux tout ce qui ne l''est
pas est inutilisable et donc plus vous
rajoutez des normes euh plus vous rendez
inutilisable l'action publique d'autant
que ces normes sont bien souvent
contradictoires et donc devant les
tribunaux euh bah vous savez pas si ça
va être pile ou si ça va être face ouais
c'est ça donc d'où oui d'ù la difficulté
d'exercer ses fonctions alors venons-en
aux relations du département avec les
les communes on dit souvent que le
département c'est le premier partenaire
des des communes c'est une phrase que
que vous faites vutre évidemment
totalement c'est l'histoire des
départements et des communes c'est un
mariage qui a deux siècles lorsque la
Révolution française transforme les
paroisses en communes elle décide aussi
d'organiser le territoire avec des
départements qui regroupent donc des
communes qui sont des communes aisé ou
des communes
pour justement que ce département puisse
prendre à ceux qui ont beaucoup pour
donner un peu à ceux qui ont moins pour
assurer aussi la circulation entre les
communes la voirie départementale et
cetera et donc ce couple depuis de
siècles fonctionne en harmonie pourquoi
vouloir le remplacer jeen vois pas très
bien l'utilité et ensuite c'est un
couple qui a fait ses preuves puisque
partout vous allez en France voyez bien
que si les communes ont les équipements
qu'elles ont des gymnases des écoles des
stades euh des mairies c'est parce qu'il
y a eu des subventions du Département il
est là pour pour jouer ce rôle le mot
technocratique c'est péréquation en
réalité c'est égalité des chances il
faut que dans chaque commune de France
on puisse avoir la même chose justement
alors il y a un cadre contractuel qui
dit le le département et les communes je
crois qu'entre 2017 et 2022 il y a eu
228 millions voilà de d'aide fourni par
le département au communes et là il y a
un nouveau cadre contractuel quels sont
les les les les grands domaines sur
lesquel il porte alors c'est toujours
les mêmes domaines on a essayé de
simplifier les formalités
administratives pour les maires pour que
justement on soit dans cette logique de
leur rendre le meilleur service de la
façon la plus simple qui soit donc il y
a désormais trois grandes catégories de
contrats la plus connue c'est les
contrats ruraux pour les mairies les
petites communes les petites commune pas
forcément en taille mais en nombre
d'habitants il y a le contrat
départemental et leat at Eveline plus et
c'est à chaque fois selon les tranches
de population mais on subventionne à peu
près tous les sujets retenons deux
choses si vous le voulez bien la
première c'est que sur les 6 dernières
années nous avons multiplié par 4 donc
depuis 2017 et jusqu'à 2022 on a
multiplié par 4 les subventions aux
communes donc c'est une aide
considérable 228 million d'euros c'est
ça exactement et la deuxième c'est que
bah l'avenir est moins souriant parce
que nous traversons mais on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure une grave crise
financière qui est liée à la crise de
l'immobilier à la crise du logement
alors ben parle de cette crise
immobilière oui qui alors qui affecte la
la France de manière générale et alors
ça çaduit une baisse de vos revenus
parce que vous prenez le les droits de
mutation sont qu'on paye chez les
notaires en gros hein sont en baisse et
et je crois qu'il a été calculé ce
serait une baisse de 140 à 150 millions
d'euros pour le dép appartement c'est ça
exactement donc ça dit pas forcément
grandchose à part que c'est beaucoup
d'argent 140 ou 150 millions il faut
savoir premièrement que les départements
n'ont plus qu'un seul impôt c'est ce
sont ces droits de mutation on en a pas
d'autres donc quand cet impôt quand cet
impôt s'effondre ce qui est le cas
puisque le marché des transactions
immobilières s'effondre du fait de la
hausse des taux
d'intérêt ou les gè et de la baisse des
constructions neuves tout ça fait que on
va avoir probablement moins de 30 % de
ressources donc 150 millions d'euros et
soyons bien conscients que ces 150
millions d'euros s'appliquent certes sur
un budget à apparence d'un milliard
d'euros mais en réalité il y a 700
millions qui sont des dépenses
obligatoires toutes les dépenses
sociales sont obligatoires elles vont
pas baisser en plus ces dépenses
sociales au vu de la crise et donc c'est
moin 150 millions rapportés sur les 300
millions d'euros que l'on distribue pour
les communes que l'on distribue pour les
associations que l'on distribue pour les
les politiques sportives et culturelles
et c'est malheureusement ce qui
fait le petit mieux le petit plus de la
vie B c'est là où on va être obligé de
faire des économies ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire une mise en péril de certains
investissements de du département ça
veut dire que le département
subventionnera le temps de la crise un
peu moins les communes enfin un peu
beaucoup moins les communes disons la
vérité tout de suite et que d'autre part
le département lui-même va différer
d'investissement j'avais pris
l'engagement au moment de la campagne
électorale de rénover 14 collèges dans
les ivelines enfin construire ou rénover
très probablement on en fera que 10 et
on reportera à la prochaine mandature
les quatre autres parce que je vois pas
où on va trouver l'argent un mot on en
parlera peut-être avec Valérie PC tout à
l'heure il y a eu un accord entre la
Région et l'État sur le les transports
enfin sur Île de France mobilité le
département a accepté de de d'augmenter
sa
contributions alors nous avons eu un
moment de tension avec île-defance
mobilité donc avec la région puisque'on
nous demandait d'augmenter de
l'inflation plus de % les les dotations
à Île-de-France mobilité c'est très
complexe he le le financement
d'ildefance mobilité retenons que les
usagers payent avec le passe Navigo que
les entreprises cootise au titre des
salariés et que les départements la
ville de Paris et la région à porte
aussi des subventions on a fini par
accepter puisque l'engagement pris par
la région c'est que cette augmentation
n''est lieu que jusqu'en 2028 et que ce
ne soit que l'augmentation de
l'inflation ensuite jusqu'en
2031 ce que je crains mais enfin soyons
pas que pessimiste c'est que ces mesures
ne suffisent pas mais en l'état actuel
nous sommes d'accord pour signer un
protocole avec la région Île-de-France
et pour voter demain au conseil
d'administration d'Île-de-France
mobilité cette clé de répartition des
financements un mot alors peut-être plus
positif il y a il y a un stand du
conseil départemental sur les Jeux
Olympiques je crois qu'il y a 14 épreuve
aux Jeux olympiques ou parallympiques
qui se tiendront dans les Yvelines
évidemment c'est un moment important
pour pour vous pour les ivelinois d'une
façon générale là aussi il y a des
investissements qui sont nécessaires
alors le département n'est pour rien
dans laavenue des épreuves olympiques
puisqu'on n'est pas par on n'est pas
partie prenante exactement c'est Paris
la sainsis mais le département a financé
des infrastructures ou des aménagements
qui ont rendu possible la tenue de ces
épreuves dans les ivelines le plus
célèbre le plus emblématique c'est le
vélodrome de Saint-Quentin iveline qui a
été largement financé par le Département
c'est la colline des lancours où il y
aura le VTT on a aussi participé au
financement du Golf National le golf
aura lieu là et au château de versa il y
aura les épesquestres euh on a financé
enfin cinancé la démolition d'un moulin
qui avait été construit dans la plaine
de Versailles qui était une horreur et
ça va permettre de retrouver la
perspective royale du château donc des
images absolument sublimes des images
uniques et puis nous avons aidé le
château à redorer ses grilles et cetera
enfin nous avons voulu participer parce
que ça doit être la fête du sport et ça
doit être là c'est c'est pas l'ivlinois
qui parle c'est le patriote ça doit être
l'occasion pour les Français de se
rassembler et d'être fier de leur pays
montrons le meilleur de la France dans
le monde entier c'est ce que je souhaite
à l'occasion de ces Jeux Olympiques en
tout cas dans les ivelines c'est ce que
nous ferons vous étiez la semaine
dernière à l'inauguration de la
Fondation Anne de gourle à Montin
Bretonneux hier vous inauguriez le
premier Centre en France de paragolf euh
là aussi oui l'inclusion l'inclusion
justement des personnes en situation de
handicap c'est c'est quelque chose que
vous poursuivez depuis longtemps 1 c'est
une mission qui nous est confiée par la
loi donc on essaye on se doit de le de
l'assumer et en plus c'est un combat et
vous évoquez la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
dans ma famille politique donc qui a été
fondé par le général de Gaulle peut-être
que celles et ceux qui nous écoutent ne
le savent pas le général a eu trois
enfants dont une petite fille une petite
fille qui est née trisomique et et ça a
été à la fois une grande joie une grande
souffrance comme toujours dans toutes
ces familles qui sont frappées par par
le handicap d'un enfant euh madame de
Gaul Yvon de Gaul a créé avec le général
en 45 euh 3 semaines 3 semaines après la
capitulation de l'Allemagne Nazi
euh il cré la fondation de Go et euh et
donc c'est un c'est un grand sujet pour
tous les département mais à niveline le
la la question du handicap est vraiment
portée par la majorité départementale
avec beaucoup de force et donc on essaie
de mettre beaucoup d'humanité et
beaucoup de moyens pour faire mieux euh
et en particulier par l'innovation alors
il y a deux étudiants de scienp qui nous
ont écouté pendant cette discussion et
qui vont vous poser une question Paul
c'est à VOUS Paul qui est donc étudiant
à sciencesp
Saint-Germain bonjour bonjour à vous
merci de m'accueillir bonjour alors ma
question elle portera sur la démocratie
comment repenser la démocratie dans nos
territoires vous avez été maire vous
êtes président du Département des
ivelines on peut dire que vous êtes un
élu de terrain alors comment on fait
pour rendre nos institutions dynamiques
et attractives dans un contexte de
montée de l'abstention notamment aux
élection départementales comment on
repense la démocratie sur les
territoires belle belle question si
j'avais la réponse mon cher Paul je
serai candidat je serai candidat à
l'élection présidentielle parce que je
seraiis un type formidable donc je crois
que on doit tous s'y mettre pas
simplement les élus pas simplement par
le vote de la loi d'abord je pense que
par l'éducation on doit rappeler et dès
le plus jeune âge que on est d'abord des
citoyen et que la citoyenneté ça
nécessite un engagement pas forcément
comme à valmi où il fallait boûter les
invasions étrangères hors de France mais
par la participation à la vie citoyenne
et ensuite du côté des élus la loi nous
y oblige souvent il faut aller au-delà
de la loi pour les élus locaux c'est
systématiquement par des réunions
quartier régulière par les réunions
légales mais aussi extralégales à faire
sur tous les projets il faut participer
expliquer faire la pédagogie des projets
faire la pédagogie des citoyens des
situations on na pas on ne peut amener
les gens à la citoyenneté que pour
autant qu'on fasse appel à leur
intelligence mais il faut que cette
intelligence il a une petite étincelle
qui est été faite à l'origine et je
crois beaucoup à la valeur de l'école je
pense que quand la République se fonde
et donc la citoyenne
émerge c'est aussi le moment où se pose
la question de l'éducation ce qui est
devenu l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui
à l'époque pardon c'était l'instruction
l'instruction publ donc c'est ce c'est
ce duo éducation participation qu'il
faut mettre en œuvre et tous pas
simplement les élus n'attendons pas que
ça tombe toujours du ciel c'est
peut-être un défaut français ça on
attend toujours d'en haut il faut aussi
qu'en bas on se bouge merci
pauloup
voilà co également étudiant à scienp
Saint-Germain bonjour qui est une très
belle école scienp Saint-Germain dont
les bâtiments appartiennent au conseil
départemental et le Conseil
départemental fait tout ce qu'il faut je
l'espère en tout cas ils vont nous le
dire s'ils sont pas cont pour que les
élèves puissent étudier dans les
meilleures conditions en tout cas on est
très fier d'avoir le sciencep de
Saint-Germain dans les ivelines vous
êtes content des le CP on est très
content je vous remercie pour cette
opportunité évidemment et donc ma
question en fait va être va être centrée
sur le fait que tout à l'heure on a pu
assister à la remise des prix remise du
Prix interdépartemental d'innovation
urbaine et en fait on a assé à on a vu
des projets assez formidable qui qui sur
le thème de ouais sur le thème de
l'agriculture urbaine de la construction
avec de différents projets centrés sur
la problématique de l'environnement de
l'énergie donc ma question va être la
suivante quel intérêt quel rôle joue le
département et surtout comment
soutenez-vous les les projets urbains
lancés par des communes par des
collectivités particulièrement quand ces
mêmes ont à cœur de s'attaquer à des
problématiques de développement durable
et donc voilà quel rôle pour selon vous
joue le département dans ce nouveau
projet urbain alors tous les projets que
vous avez vu les communes n'étaient pas
en situation de pouvoir les financer
toutes seul donc il fallait des
subvention départementale et
systématiquement je parle pour les
Yvelines tous les projets désormais
doivent avoir une connotation
développement durable pour pouvoir
aspirer à une subvention c'est
l'innovation qui nous sortira de la
crise climatique on l'a créé le le génie
humain a créé cette crise climatique
puisque elle est le résultat de du
processus industriel de ce qu'on appelle
le monde développé il faut que
maintenant cette même intelligence nous
aide à sortir de cette crise autrement
le drame est devant nous merci Cyril
merci Pierre béer et bonnes université
merci cher Patrice c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous retrouver à l'occasion
de cette université et je dois dire que
vous avez aujourd'hui un costume
absolument extraordinaire j'ai
l'impression d'être en plein été grâce à
vous et pas simplement grâce au
réchauffement climatique merci merci
beaucoup